what do you want for her that i'm not
giving her
randy's wiener dude can we talk about if
we're really gonna go there
randy your dog was licking my dog's
peepee and i don't think that is normal
he no he's in his peepee phase carlos
told me that means
randy has a vitamin deficiency oh like
pica
pica that's like when people like start
eating cement blocks
because they have their low in iron or
even like pregnant women when they
get started getting deplete off of the
baby starts to suck all the nutrients
they start to like um crave like
lint i'm just so like sad i wasn't able
to like you didn't do a behind the
scenes of you
having the conversation with carlos
where you come to him shaken
that my dog molested your dog we go to
the only person we know that really has
the inside scoop of
dogs i was like yeah randy was licking
in her vagina like is that normal
i was all victimed out and carl was like
it's not normal
he's got something wrong but you told me
you said it was normal
yeah the articles that we read said that
he like when they
when they're doing that they're just
like getting to know they're like
downloading i feel like that's all
i see dogs do lick the pee pee but yeah
i mean randy does get his mouth under
the stream like he's like he gets
donut like he wets her whole peepee area
and she's just
it's it makes me sad that is that nice
why let her live she doesn't like it
oh my god we're gonna play this i'm
suing you
george get the papers out there are
papers if you guys are wondering there
are papers ready there's a desk with a
little key
george swallowed the key so we really
need a chance to [ __ ] in like a little
kid
toilet and then we go through with a
popsicle stick but we will get the key
back when we need to sign those
[Music]
annie have you been doing jiu-jitsu um
oh do i have bruises
you have bruises all over your this show
no i got i
i went and got um acupressure from this
guy who was
he was vaccinated my guy kung fu
acupuncture i've been waiting but he
[ __ ] me up
he has like nubs for fingers and i'm i
want to ask him next time i have to film
it because
i need the world to know but i want to
ask him if he cut them off on purpose to
be able to like push the
the points the points what he's got
little nub fingers
he's the best so you think that it was a
voluntary
um amputation finger amputation it's
that or
he really knows how to work with what
happens in his life and he leaned in he
got the finger cut off and he's like
what's something that i could like
that's something that i considered when
i was 18 and wanted to be like
the best [ __ ] queen i always used to
tell people
are these two women i'm doing this show
with that's what i want to know i used
to tell people
babysitter go to bed [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no snack for you cunn
i used to tell um i used to tell people
that i wanted i couldn't wait to have
enough money to get my teeth removed
so i could just gum a dick oh my god i
so relate to like being
because it was like i think that there
were two choices in high school you were
either a cocktails or like a [ __ ]
for some reason cocktails was like the
biggest the worst so i couldn't believe
yeah and then i'm like they tricked us
into thinking cocktails was bad
cocktails was good
it was the best that's how you get
married
you [ __ ] tease them is that why we're
all unmarried
i can't will you tell us when you
finally um lose your virginity to dave
and donut will be there so don't act
like you're not
um a sexual unit wait i have a question
is acupressure cupping it's not this was
all a hand did all these
so then what is acupressure acupressure
is like a very deep painful massage at
different points
but the yeah it's this like old asian
man
who um he pushes it hurts so but i told
you about him because he came up with
tmj
oh i want to know but it's the most
painful like you have to suffer through
like a lot i like to suffer in a massage
same why are you looking at me i just
like i
i just if i'm being completely honest a
vision of you getting a massage
okay and then you're down face down and
then they say like how's the pressure
and you say good and then i switch out
with them
beat the [ __ ] out of your knots honestly
i think i would love that
do you ever like don't you feel like a
massage is
like really intimate and like almost
sexual
well i have a story what i went to
i'm so dumb like i i guess i didn't
realize that there's like girl versions
of happy ending salons like i just
we're spas like i just i went to i had a
really bad back
this was like six years ago really bad
back
um i and it was like midnight everything
was closed and there was like i found
this place that was open 24 hours and it
didn't even occur to me
it was like oh my god that's like what a
great service to have and it was like
the massages are 20 an hour i was like
that's really cheap that's awesome
no red flags i go by myself what city
it was in [ __ ] burbank so i go
i go and you know what we this show
doesn't need both of us
one of us can go can i decide
each episode i decide who's invited back
i'm so happy it's nearby so okay so i go
and they give me this guy and i i
usually like i would go for the guy
at places because i know they'll go
harder than the girls wait
really i've never wait i'm sorry i don't
want to interrupt you but
you're going to remove their little
hands i only ever request email and i
won't do mail
no it's appropriate it's i don't know
why i have to relive like
full molestations every time i get a
[ __ ] massage
you said you like when i like when they
go very deep emotionally deep in my
massages as well
this is crazy but okay so so i go to
this place it's like one in the morning
i pay my 20 dollars i go in and
you know how when they put the sheet on
you they just when they're working on
one part they just move like one limb
out
like yeah and the rest the whole sheet
was taken off
he massaged my [ __ ] open like
massaging my butt cheeks open
like wind was going into my vagina and i
don't have a thigh gap or anything like
it's wind doesn't get up there often
like he was spreading them in a way that
they'd never been spread
and i was like oh for sure pictures are
being taken of me
like he kept leaving the room and coming
back and then and he was like armenian
and he was like
so hairy but he had shaved so i was it
was weird because it was a bad
experience but also you don't realize
that like having that sort of like
gravelly
scratchy thing rubbing on you feels good
it was like i was getting like a salt
scrub too with his lips
so but so and i remember i was like
and he was like kind of young and like
not a guy i wouldn't bend like it was
i i remember i was looking down in the
little hole at his shoes and he was
wearing like
the same type of shoes my boyfriend had
and i was like i don't think a guy
giving a massage at midnight should
have the same shoes [ __ ]
they were like i think they were um
they were air force ones but they could
have been tim's they were the sneaker
version of tim's
i feel like if he wasn't tim's you would
have not resisted you would have been
well he wouldn't have had to use any oil
i would have been squirting all over
myself but it was like so uncomfortable
and
when he had the i go i went dude come on
put the [ __ ]
cover me up a little bit yes and then i
realized like i
when i left i was like i can't even be
mad at this guy like i walked into a
very obvious
no you could be mad i don't think he was
trying to grab my ass for himself
he was trying to give me like i'm
assuming people pay 20 and then they
would
tip them like a hundred to like i need
exactly i need exact cross streets
i i i will try to find it i was doing
that for himself that was not for you
he was he wanted to see your poo poo
area
um i went to this gynecologist in
philadelphia my mom
like refer found him and referred me to
him and i went and
he stuck his finger in my [ __ ]
like up my butt and i was like uh and
right when he stuck his finger at my ass
he went um are you
tim letterman's sister and i was like i
swear to god and they like pull and i'm
like
yeah and he goes oh i just put it two
and two together with your last name and
i when you said you were a comedian
and he's like oh your brother he's like
meanwhile he's just swinging this finger
that's been my answer
he's like your brother and my son were
in the same frat
and i like partied with them i would go
party with them
and then he was like next time you have
a show in town you need to i gotta come
i was like you do
i mean why is your finger in my ass my
whole response is like why is and then i
talked to my mom and she's like
i think they've done that to me before
and i'm like i don't know what old
school
butt fingering is going on another
another thing male gynecologist
stay away i'm not and i know that maybe
is offensive but that's i don't i'm not
comfortable
what if we got like hate mail from mel
i'm fine with male gynecologists what
annie so you went to juvenile delinque
delinquent school is this how you ended
up in mexico at 14
my high school was very small it was
like
my graduating class had 17 kids in it
like it was just a tiny little
alternative school so it was half bad
kids and half
like kids with learning disabilities so
i was a little bit of both
they we had spring trips and one spring
trip when i was 14
they took a group of us like the worst
none of the
ld kids went it was only the like young
criminals went on this one
we went to mexico during cinco de mayo
to look at the mayan ruins
but we did that one day and the rest
like the teachers were [ __ ] up
everyone was wasted
i went with my boyfriend and my best
friend at the time this girl becky and
we were all like under one guy was over
18 and
so with our our hotel rooms we got bands
to get free alcohol
but i think you're 14. but we were under
but you have to be 18 to drink in mexico
what is that permission you're 14. i
want to know what that permission slip
looked like for your parents to sign
well they also signed i was allowed to
smoke cigarettes they signed the smoking
cigarettes
stop yeah why they just
your parents allowed you at 14 to smoke
cigarettes why
i guess they just didn't want me to i
think my mom is afraid i was going to
run away
my mom was trying to be like friends she
wanted to be like buds with me
she was like felt overprotected so then
she was like do anything i was like oh
my god
i've been running for my life so many
times i've been hiding under cars
screaming to call the cops i feel like
they're two ways to parent
that parent and then my parent who at 14
couldn't stop making me kneel on rock
salt as punishment
you know so it's like i could do nothing
she could do everything i feel like
you're the healthy in between maybe
i think i am yeah it's sad if we think
she was raised healthy did everybody
watch esther's special
we are all agreeing that she was the
healthiest raised person
and i really need you to watch how
[ __ ] tragic that is
please go to her special hat for her
name for my name
well mine was like go go doubt do things
and then like if something seemed
dangerous it was like no you're in
trouble
but also you're not gonna do anything
dangerous yeah you're like self
there was one time where i was policed
it was when i wanted to go to a dropkick
murphy's concert because
because my cool friends did in eighth
grade and that was i got in trouble
i didn't get to go you would have been
smashed up in that mushroom so they were
just they were right hacky sacked across
the
and i had no idea what i was agreeing to
or getting into so i
now see that that was when did you get
the height that you are like what
i don't know because you could have been
this this is a regular kindergartners
size i know i was always small were you
a premier
no you guessed normal how tall is your
how tall is your sister
five five oh she's like normal yeah
that's like a giant yeah my mom is short
but my mom is five three she's taller
than five foot
did she take prenatals for her second
child i don't know
but she does say that she only famously
only gained like eight pounds when she
was pregnant with me
oh she victoria beckham did did she tell
you that
when you were a freshman in college yes
she did oh my god you gained more weight
than i did when i was pregnant
that's exactly correct okay so tell me
in mexico
okay so we go to mexico and
we can't drink none of they they tell
the
our bar in our hotel like each like
hotel area had its own bar they were
like none of these kids don't let any of
them drink even though we had our bands
they don't give a [ __ ] don't let them
drink but they were not letting us drink
so
there was this kid marty who was 18 and
he just went over to the bar
next to us and he would bring his drinks
back yeah
okay so background story
uh like a month before i had been
hanging out at the guy whose virginity i
lost
house which was my boyfriend at the time
at the waterbed the waterbed guy you
lost it to him
i lost my virginity he was my boyfriend
i was obsessed with him
he was really into my friend so anyway
so
we're at his house and she was hooking
up with becky was hooking up with his
friend
and we were there and i said he said i
said something i said she was ticklish
or something i did something that was
like
to her this like horrible betrayal and
she slapped me across the face and it
was really crazy and everyone was like
did you just slap and i was like
and then she was like oh i'm sorry and i
was like all right well i'm gonna slap
you back
when it's appropriate like it's fine
we're all good but like your slap's on
its way
when you step out of line you're getting
[ __ ] slapped so that was our deal
so then like a month later we're in
mexico
and marty it's like annoying for marty
to have to keep over going over and get
drinks and they're like kind of catching
on so we have to like
pace out him getting our drinks so marty
brings
the round of drinks over and i like turn
away for a second and this
guy this kid that used to bully me
picked it up and drank it and everyone
was just laughing
behind my back and i like looked over
and he had chugged my drink
and i was like felt like such a you know
i was like you know
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know it was just
like everyone's laughing at me so then
marty's like it's all right i'll just go
get you another one like he's a dick
whatever so marty goes over gets me
another one
i turn around i'm talking um becky
chugs my drink that's the girl that
slapped you yes okay this is my best
friend
so yeah this is like ride or die like we
supposed to have each other's backs
quick quick question why did she slap
you did she have a good reason
because she she was mad because i told
this guy asked her she was ticklish and
i said she was
that's why she slapped you that's
something you would be mad at me
i wouldn't i just want to be spirit i've
never slapped or been slapped
oh my goodness is that a challenge
[Laughter]
esther and it shows
i know you could be you could have a
pigtail tugged out
or two i wouldn't say those type of
things in front of annie
i feel like she's just foaming at the
mouth waiting to just i'm like oh i
never got to take anyone's virginity
this is a type of virginity the lawsuit
that i would somehow muster up all right
start drinking some diuretics we're
gonna have to poop that key out
she's getting ready for it to file the
paper okay keep going okay so she drinks
so yes so she drinks my drink everyone's
laughing at me again and it's just like
the emotions going through my head that
i remember are like being humiliated
for the second time and the fact that
this [ __ ] is selling me out
to try to look cool at my expense right
now
like so i just whenever i slapped her
right i just went
now it's your turn and i slapped her
okay but nobody was there except my ex
or my boyfriend at the time had seen her
slammy before so she then
really victimed it up and i mean this
was like a shake we did like it was like
you're going to get slapped
your turn she like it was like how dare
you how could you and i'm like you got
to be [ __ ] kidding me and then i'm
trying to get brad to be on my side and
he's trying to [ __ ] her so
and i'm like are you guys kidding me so
i was like livid and then
we all ended up getting so [ __ ] drunk
that the next day the one day we
actually had a field trip where we went
to go see these mayan ruins
i vomited all over the bus like all over
my ex-boyfriend's like i don't i think
he had new balances like all of his new
balances
and just all over everyone um so i
definitely probably had like the most
dramatic time even though everyone else
did and then we um
so i was like in a fight with her she
also i remember brad and i were banging
on the
on the um balcony and she came out there
it was like why would you come out where
we're banging
she just was always a problem and kind
of like [ __ ] blocking me or like
trying to [ __ ] my boyfriend she was
always like banging on my it was like
such a weird
did she like your boyfriend all every
boyfriend i had
so and he liked her back he had a crush
on her she was dating
she lost her virginity to this other guy
we like lost her virginity at the same
time
and then i started dating him and then
he ended up breaking up with me when we
got back from mexico because he said he
didn't like how i treated
becky and i was like but you know the
whole story so it was like he just and
then they
they had been hooking up i didn't know
that during the mexico trip
uh i don't know yeah that's what i was
gonna show you i was hooking up with
this other guy mike who was my friend
liz's boyfriend
who she [ __ ] with liz and liz
liz died in a very pr in a very
shocking but appropriate way for herself
like and not a girl you want to [ __ ]
with so liz has
since expired she is no longer with us
oh wow
but liz what happened to liz okay so liz
wasn't on that trip but when i came back
i was like
liz was a queen liz was like a very she
was supposed to be in a school for
juvenile delinquents like she was very
much she really liked watching
heavenly creatures that movie about
killing her oh i love that no but
she liked to watch she owned it on vhs
kate winslet yeah where they kill their
parents
yeah i like that movie as a child too
well i didn't
i was not kneeling on rocks all right my
parents just sent me to places where men
made me know i wasn't just
i wasn't just kneeling on rock salt by
the way i was i was told to keep my arms
to my side like this but i will tell you
this you do have great arms
do you like my sweaty armpits my my pits
are gonna sweat so bad i wore the wrong
sweat color
[Music]
you guys i cannot believe the sponsor
that we got i
like i have been a user for the last two
years
it's the gift i got for every for
everyone in my family for christmas last
year it's
was it gelt jewish scout no you got them
just a little jewish chocolate
it's theragan like i'm starstruck that
they want to work with us
are we sure we're sure theragun is the
handheld percussive therapy device that
releases your deepest muscle tension
using a scientifically
calibrated combo of depth speed
and power and it's as quiet as an
electric toothbrush
the gen 4 theragun doesn't just feel
good it gets to the source of the pain
by releasing tension using theragun's
signature percussive therapy which goes
sixty percent deeper than vibration
alone no joke like
we used to use this on the set of crazy
ex-girlfriend people would bring them
and we would all theragon each other
it's like you can't not have one and it
saves you money because you don't need
to go pay for massages you guys it has
honestly
cut my recovery in half if if i'm doing
hit training that day
and i'm really sore the next day this is
my go-to
we get it you work out i know she's
gonna say ask her have you ever felt the
way she's feeling
i'm fit i'm just sore from the way i sit
on my couch
i really feel like people have heard of
theragon like now is the time to support
bloodbath and support yourself and save
money by not having to go get massages
and be touched by people
you guys try theragon for 30 days
starting at only 199
which is actually saving you money go to
theragon.com
bloodbath right now and get your gen 4
theragun today that's theragun.com
bloodbath theragon.com bloodbath
it's it it saves you money i'm not
having to go get massages like this is a
no-brainer this is a time
you can theragon while you listen to
annie verbally theragan me
[Laughter]
my my mom was like maria do you guys
know who maria abramovic is
she's a performance artist she does like
really extreme things with like
you know physical like she has like her
art exhibit involves human bodies
my mom was maria abramovic with her
torture tactics the the rock salt is
like the least creative thing she's ever
come up with
she had this thing called stomach belt
do you want that stomach belt
it she was very creative she had this
other one where she
was a stomach belt right now to cover
this muffin top that's hanging out
but she would whip you with like a rhino
[ __ ] hide whip
and then she also had this other um um
she used banana peels as a weapon and
she would take them
would she put them underneath so you
slid on them that's pretty your mom's
funny cartoon
she would just anything's cartoons are
real
i mean it explains you perfectly
she knows she would whip our faces with
a banana peel she would eat a banana
that's exactly what she did she would
eat a banana and she would be just and
you knew it was coming like
like rageful and we were across the
[ __ ] table from her
like oh god it's coming it's coming she
would just get up and [ __ ]
whip our faces with banana also her
mom's really hot so
this by the way when i ask her now
when i ask her now because that's why we
you know when kids tell their stories
they're like oh my parents used to beat
me
and then you see their mom and the mom's
like you know middle age or 60 years old
and she looks like just the sweetest old
lady
that is not my mom my mom is a [ __ ]
asian
arnold schwarzenegger i got beaten by
like i love
bodybuilding i got beaten by a
bodybuilder like i remember having to
spend two hours one time trying to like
pluck my braces wire off of like my lips
because it was lodged in there from her
just like [ __ ] punching me in the
mouth
what but um she had very full lips for a
week again
we like to take our trauma and we like
to really see the positives
she learned to she has very tough knees
now
i do very very um someone once said i
had really
like um meaty knees i'm like that's all
scar tissue from [ __ ] kneeling you
[ __ ]
you're like feel it there's rock salt
inside i
can we try all the things that your mom
did on you and esther we should
there is something really funny to me
like memory sense
memory wise about like the moment where
you know you just [ __ ] up and like you
know you're about to get in trouble from
like your older sibling or your parent
like they're
like the moment of them eating like
you're saying she ate the banana
and you're just like without waiting you
know they're about to come over and yell
at you
or something is so funny it's yeah it's
inevitable that's why i am adult that
um you know like i do this a lot like i
wince a lot
at anything like the air i'm like what's
that i do that too and no one even
beat me beated you i can't even say it
but i'm always like i'm always like
but maybe that's how you got away from
it because that you gave them the jerk
reaction already and they were like
that's good enough
like you showed fear that's what we were
supposed to do so my sister was really
smart she was like why don't you just
cry
right away she's like you're so stupid
no but i like that where you're like
come on [ __ ] give me more
yeah that's exactly the type of kid that
i was i was like
you don't get to break me down i
remember
the exact day because my parents weren't
like i remember my parents like
gripping me up a couple times but i mean
that was like really after a lot
um but my dad never my dad was like when
he was little so he never does it my mom
like
she never did anything like she's like
ripped our leg or like smacked my leg
once hard and she feels so guilty
put on the waterworks and just like
really dig in and make her feel bad
and she choked me up once when i was 14.
but it was like the day i was like i
smoke cigarettes i
[ __ ] and i have my nipples pierced
[Laughter]
no i i remember when i was like much
younger like i have a couple memories of
like
the someone going and getting the
yardstick
and like threatening with the yardstick
to make you do math
but not nothing no i don't remember
anything else but this is like a pr this
is a perfect science experiment it's
like
verbal abuse physical abuse no abuse but
we're all still
mentally [ __ ] up [ __ ] up yeah so
it's like they're
so funny and cute there's nothing like
how did that happen we got so cute and
funny
but like you know when you were talking
about being at jcpenney that makes you
think of
college when like being in the dressing
room at banana republic with my mom and
her just being like
i'm like nothing looks good and she's
like well why'd you have to gain so much
weight
like that's abuse i like that i like
that you're like
speaking of being beaten with banana
peels i was at banana republic
or like in eighth grade changing and my
mom being like
oh my god you have stretch marks that's
so young
you have stretch marks like that you did
yeah
no that is no having like um
your parents kind of put their body
stuff on you because my parents are big
dieters and stuff so i definitely got
all of my
my like negative eating things for my
parents but that's bad yeah that's like
a weird pressure competition
you know they always say like your um
what your parents say
to you become your internal dialogue so
i'm a selfish [ __ ]
but that's i'm an untalented not i'm
just undead maybe they're just helping
you yeah
i deserve to die i should be executed
oh i know i do have like i've realized
this i discovered this in therapy last
year
like when we were talking about putting
on a swimsuit and i was like i can't no
matter what like i can't put on a
swimsuit i i do still to this day i swim
in a t-shirt and shorts
i didn't i was like i don't know why i'm
like this like i actually
i was saying like i feel comfortable in
a broad underwear like i cannot wear a
swimsuit
and i was like you know there was this
one incident but it was it had a yeast
infection no
beasties i was like well yeah there was
this one time like but
it didn't bother me where i was in
middle school
and i was at the like the local pool and
i took off my swim covers and i heard
like the older girls
say to them to each other like oh my god
i didn't know she was fat
and i'm like and at the time i remember
i remember being really confident about
it i was like oh [ __ ]
like i don't care whatever but now i'm
like oh i think that
my therapist was like i think that's why
and the best part is that they were
probably talking about a person next to
you and you just your whole life has
been ruined by it i think they were
talking about me
but how can you be so short and fat
though i don't understand you're so
little
i'm like i'm like soft
yeah but it was like just like mean girl
calling it it was me bro they were mean
girls here how about this
maybe we can work towards the goal of um
getting you
in a really nice high-cut flattering
swimsuit i'll wear one with you
um my bush is gonna fly out of there
annie will wear one we can have like a
very
um healthy episode of us
in one piece not two peas just you know
just to kind of sit down with that
i don't care what's going on with my
body i'm in a bikini are you serious how
do you have that confidence no offense
it's just like
it's just it's just here's what every
time i feel fat i just remind myself i'm
fertile as [ __ ] that's cool i'm just
like sorry i'm fertile
you all want to bang me anyone that's
calling me fat is trying to have sex
with me
yeah yes yes but what do you think about
those goals esther is that is that a
weird i would
love to do that but i can all i can
think about like my
thighs on this chair but they say you
know exposure therapy
have you ever heard of that where it's
just you do the things that make you
uncomfortable and then you see
if you can get through it and that tiny
bit of confidence you're like oh i got
through it
yeah i'm open to that i don't want like
bored short esther to go away though
at a pool party esther is golden she's
like wearing umbros
and obviously one of her tie-dyed shirts
she's dressed like exactly like
me when everybody thought i looked like
the middle hanson brother in middle
school
i threw on my puka shell necklace wait a
second idle taylor
yeah i look like the middle one no i
think you look like daniel johns
from silver chair
yeah all of when i was at my most
vulnerable physically vulnerable
emotional
place in middle school i looked like
every famous
boy every famous hot blonde boy but they
were the hot blond boys that
my brothers accidentally jerked off to
thinking they were girls so i can give
myself that
what was the guy from home improvement
oh jonathan taylor jonathan
thomas yeah i honestly carly akula do
you guys know her
yeah she um she used to always send me
like memes of him and be like this is he
jt wait um george can we pull up a
picture of
um middle school esther and annie no
oh i have a really good middle school
when i didn't send you guys oh
that's okay let's get that little cute
look at your mom look at the shirt that
says i lied to
girls that's very honest of you i
thought i was like i dressed like a
horny boy
wait was this like a kappa shirt is that
what the brand was yeah
i think it is yeah it was christina my
best friend's
twin brothers shirt and how how old were
you here
that's probably like seventh grade okay
i was right so it is middle school yeah
okay you're you i remember which middle
school picture you have of me which is
like there's a year before so post this
one and then i'll send you
so i just realized i think that one was
actually freshman year of college
because or high school
i knew this was going to happen this is
stupid i think this is
i don't know eighth grade or freshman
year i i think i had the blonde
highlights
what at you trying to pretend to be a
christian my dad made us do that
you guys i don't i don't know if i this
goes without saying but i do think i
need to let you guys know that i was
really obsessed with
the lifetime movie about amy fisher i
don't know if you can tell by this
who's that amy fisher um she shot the
wife of the guy she was
having an affair with back in the day
she was like a you know
like a jody arias and she yeah she was
like my queen i feel like to draw
pictures of her i loved her it was like
her and paula abdul were my idols
[Laughter]
i feel like this is very this picture is
very true to the times
yeah like with a necklace the eyebrows
is it green eyeshadow even it's white
but that's also a that's a um
a picture from my qui a quaker youth
retreat
more importantly who were the bald
ghosts in the background
those are some quakers i my picture i
look so
ugly and you look like a pretty girl
well i'm gonna try to find my ugly boy
one
i had had sex with my one boyfriend i
had lost
did you lose your virginity fourteen
this is the age i lost my virginity
and then i remember i started to get
insecure because
on this trip some guy it was the first
time someone told me that i looked like
brett butler
and it was when grace under fire was on
and i was so offended because she
i mean she was probably 35 at that point
but to me she was like a 90 year old
woman
they were saying i looked like wait can
we also like rebrand
the term losing your virginity like
there's something so yeah
creepy creepy like something to be taken
it's so disgusting
what can we call that that's not so
creepy and misogynistic i like to say
cherry popping's fun
my mom no i can't use my mom's term
because that's even worse the
deflowering
ew yeah deflowering it's like so it's
not a flower
yeah it's like what is it a rotten
[ __ ] dorian it's a durian
that's why i like it kala when did you
have sex for the first time um at
15 with a boy named jaime
you gave your hymen to jaime that is
really amazing
was he one of your step brothers he was
not my this was
a couple years before sex with my steps
does it even count if it's not a brother
it i don't know you guys make the rules
is it was it real sex with him behind
but i was so unready and i knew it
because as soon as
we were done i wanted to break up with
him right away and i did
i was like i can't do this anymore my
body rejected the experience but leading
up to it i was so horny
i was so horny that's all i wanted to do
but then when it was done i was like
oh god you like suck dicks and stuff
before you lost your virginity because i
was like
very scared of penises and like very not
ready to [ __ ] but was like
i gotta keep this sweet guy i can't yeah
i thought i was like everyone else i
thought it was like a late bloomer
everyone else that i was friends because
we were juvenile delinquents had been
like banging since before their period
yeah so i was like i better i better hit
it quick
what about you esther i mean i was 15
too so that's young like it's
yeah 15. but with a boyfriend but that
you liked
yeah i liked it he was the guy that like
i had a crush on for a year
wasn't johnny rocket's boy it was johnny
rockets no wonder
no wonder what why do you call it
getting johnny rocketed
because we were talking about um your
biggest heartaches um
in the first episode and you had
mentioned johnny rocket's betrayal
that is like my high school boyfriend
that
broke my heart and yeah this is the dry
drive by his house yeah
you should drive by his house she's
living you know yes i don't but i also
have stories to share about that
oh do you want to do a drive-by stories
because i've got a very good drive-by
story too
what in college i got caught driving by
i got okay so i dated this guy you know
that's my dream is to get caught
it's just this was very bad okay so
it was not my dream to get caught my
dream was to get taken back by this
person that didn't even it was okay so
i i dated this guy there was this guy
and i had
i had a crush on him for like two years
he was bald it was like
he was a a prematurely bald kid in my
class but he was so funny that i was
like
i'm gonna get that bald guy like he's
gonna be my boyfriend and he had a
girlfriend the first year and then i
remember i even saw him my mom was like
visiting
and we were at red lobster and i saw him
with his girlfriend i was like i have a
crush on that guy
and the next uh semester i called my mom
and i was like
guess who's sitting in front of me like
ball bald guy and i was like well i
guess we should call him balder because
more is gone
and she was like oh my god and then so
then i started hanging out with him and
we
like started dating and he was so funny
and i was so in love with him and he was
like you have to come to tennessee and
meet my family
wait what age i was uh 19.
he was like you have to come to
tennessee to meet my family like
everyone in my family was like this
finally you have like a good boyfriend
who like gets how cool you are and great
i go to um i go home
for christmas and i'm supposed to fly up
for new year's to meet his family
he stops returning my calls after he
drops me off at the airport
no response on email or anything then
calls me on christmas eve and is like
yeah just cancel your just cancel
why your trip he was like my parents are
getting divorced and i just
we went it's just like the thing that
i've done this to so many guys since so
you know i now understand the other side
but you know when you just you're really
into someone in the beginning and you
make a lot of like future plans
and then you wake up one morning and
you're like who are i don't want this
life like you just aren't into it and
you just have to now like
go back on these promises that you made
it was just like that and that was my
worst fear i mean
the fact that it hasn't happened i mean
i wish i could make it happen to you i
wish there was a way i could
find a way to just have dave just wake
up when what no i wouldn't can you
imagine
i mean let's not even joke about that
side wait so what's the driver okay so
then
i just want to give you like the intense
background so um
so then he like lived in this house with
a couple other people that was up this
was all in santa fe so
people like live on a mountain in an
arroyo like it's like a weird
you know it's like desert land and
mountain so
he lived on the street that was like up
this hill and you had to go past this
really nice
um really nice hotel that my friend
trevor worked at
so i there's no reason for me to be
driving that direction unless i'm going
to trevor's or ryan's house
so i go i drive by it all the time i'm
so heartbroken that like this was like i
thought we were gonna like get married i
mean
you know i was younger it's an olivia
rodrigo song yeah it's 100
that song and i'm like i just can't
believe it and one time i even went over
and they moved out and they were doing
renovations on the house so it was
unlocked so i was able to go
into the house that's an atlantis
morissette song
that's yeah and it was like crime it was
a full dream well
lock your door um don't tell me on
christmas
um um stay with me um
but so then i'm driving one of the times
i'm going to drive by and i was doing it
pretty frequently
like very cocky like nobody had caught
me and when they were living there i was
doing it too and it was hard because it
was up
like pretty much a dead end like you
could drive by it but
it was a very like very rarely used
driveway-like street so i had gotten
away with it so many times i got very
cocky
and i was driving one day and trevor was
outside smoking a cigarette on a break
and he was like annie and he like pulls
me over and goes are you driving by
right like he just there was no
other thing i could be doing and he just
called it out immediately and i was like
um i gotta go my window's broken i gotta
get out of here i
drove up drove off a cliff i fell in
louise myself
it was just so funny did you ever talk
after that to trevor
yeah trevor is the guy who broke up with
you no trevor was his friend that worked
at the thing but
no i'm still i went to his wedding i
went to ryan's wedding he he ended up
marrying a girl i was friends with i
moved her out to la to live with him
but i do think that she really liked the
fact that
he had broken my heart and that's why
she wanted me at the wedding
oh my gosh like i brought the clown i
mean not that they don't love each other
and have kids and stuff but she loved
that like
i was like this cute stepping stone yeah
do you know what's a joke is if one if
any of the three of us think that we
don't need so much of better health
it we need triple the amount of better
help we need to be seeing
three different therapists i would say
psychology major just because we would
do role playing and i would get extra
therapy in class
it is so convenient you don't have to
leave your house it's again
safe and private and you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
so that means right now from this point
you will be talking to someone within
two days
when you're triggered by something that
we've talked about on this podcast you
can immediately get help
this is an app you can find someone
right away you don't have to wait
you don't have to suffer alone there is
someone that will listen to your
problems and talk it out with you and
find your patterns and tell you
that maybe you should stop being friends
with some of your friends
my favorite feature of better help is
you can write your counselor at any time
there's a journal feature
so all throughout the week even before
your next appointment you can just write
down your thoughts that your
therapist now has access to so going
into your appointment
you're not starting from scratch she's
going to be like okay these things have
happened throughout the week let's talk
about it that's so helpful
it is and just to be clear it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
actually professional counseling that is
done securely online
and like kalila said you can send a
message to your counselor anytime and
you'll get thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video or
phone sessions the best part is that it
is very affordable and financial aid is
available
and honestly like better help is that
thing that i've i've heard about for a
while
and i say take it from these three old
rotten sperms
esther and klyla now is the time to use
it we all use better help and we are so
much better off for it i don't think we
would get through this
show without using better help annie i
want you to start living a happier life
today and as a listener
of bloodbath you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's
betterhelp help.com
bloodbath give your partner a break they
don't want to hear your problems anymore
go to professional okay it's on your
phone it's that easy
esther what about you because it didn't
just happen one time
you go you still frequent and you still
drive by
yeah they have like a johnny camera
because of you
here's here's the thing i drive by his
house
you know my best friend knows how to
drive pi
you know i was home in december and my
mom and i were running errands and i was
like oh we're right by you know
so we're in 2020 yeah so we so i drive
by
i'm curious it's a curiosity it's also a
memory lane situation you know you're
i'm not just revisiting that
love i'm revisiting my past that time in
your life yeah like
you know and he represents that time he
also is the only ex i have that i don't
speak to
that i you know that has blocked well
yeah yeah so you don't speak to him or
does he not speak to you
he's completely blocked me he's so funny
to block it
he's blocked my phone number blocked me
on facebook how long
ago a long time ago because i remember
the night where like i crossed the line
and it was like right when i moved to la
and i remember i was bored in my acting
class
and i just started texting him like mean
stuff and like
like what it's like i was just like oh
your new girlfriend is
just like me but fatter
i like how you knocked yourself a little
bit better you didn't want to be
unrealistic
about it obviously i don't stand by that
i was stupid i was 21 years old i was a
jerk and i was a jealous
idiot um she seems lovely i'm happy for
them
i just i would love to connect i would
love to have a positive conversation
um run never unblock by the way i love
you in acting class texting
i know you're like sexting and texting
in glass um
and you know i know his parents probably
hate me everyone hates me whatever but
um yeah and then the okay the bad thing
that i did that i should not have done
is i'm so i'm still friends with
one of my friends my friend bobby
is not bobby lee bobby kazorski hey
bobby um
which bobby was like the cute guy in our
school and all my friends had sex with
bobby but bobby and i never had like we
were just always friends
and so bobby one night tells me
when i was home in chicago whatever like
five years ago he's like oh actually
it's so funny you're in town it's the
their wedding party is tonight in
here in chicago because they i guess it
got married and
okay i know where in miami i'm not gonna
say that wait who who got married johnny
rockets boy yeah he married the french
girl
not the french girl he married the next
girl the french fry girl
the fat french girl um
so no she's actually cuban which i'm
very jealous of because i've always
wanted to have half cuban babies because
my best friend is cuban anyway is that
racist i don't know
so
so i'm jealous of a lot of things so
anyways
uh so bobby's like oh they they're
having their like in town wedding for
all the people that couldn't make it to
florida
and i was like really like oh my god i'm
coming
and i guess bobby thought i was joking
but then i called bobby and i'm like me
and christina are outside
and he comes out and he's like what are
you doing here and i was like
i'm just like outside like i'm not going
in did you think he was gonna like tie
sheets together and help you climb up
i just thought i was so stupid that i
thought it was funny i was like this is
funny like i'm here i'm outside like
come outside
i'm gonna look like and bobby was just
like this is crazy
you're crazy and we were all laughing it
was funny okay
i got the laughs but i get that i should
not
have you even been near the building
isn't it weird when you get these
moments as a grown-up where
you realize like you just like the story
that you have with that person is just
like
done like you're like trying to go back
i've like revisited so many
ex-boyfriends and it's the same thing
where they're like
can you leave my life like i've come
back and been like i'm ready to [ __ ] you
again and they're like
what can you go away there is some
some type i think they haven't been
waiting for us to make our appearance
again
there i read this one thing about like
that's one of the hallmark science of
i don't know what it was i don't think
it was narcissism but it was like some
type of like personality disorder where
you feel the need to make good or to be
friends with all of your exes
yeah um that is a red flag so
really yeah it's it's okay to never
speak to somebody you had a falling out
with and
and i kind of mister do you mind never
calling me again
no but esther funny that you say that
he's like the only guy who's like
completely like an ex of yours is
completely cut out
i'm gonna make a plea to bradley
vanderkam
to please forgive me for for all the
things that i
did he has blocked me off of everything
our love affair happened when i was 17
and he has not
he has not relented he probably died of
old age wasn't he like 70
why if you were underage he was probably
over age
all the bloodbath babes have to have an
x that's blocked them that's a
requirement
george really what a time to bring up
what annie calls my prison yard picture
i know i'm like you have to be waiting
outside of prison
there can't be another place you're at
by the way i'm dressed like you
in that picture now
i was wearing sketcher slides by the way
with you know with a with a thick heel
on it i'm so glad the feet part got cut
out of that picture
wow but that was not me in college
george i hadn't met bradley vanderkam
then but um i
was so he was the first guy that i
[ __ ] over
i had never cheated on him but he's the
only boy i've ever cheated on
but i [ __ ] him over and i was so sure
that he was going to have me back and he
didn't and not only did he cut me off
like
even today in her 30s like i i don't
even have the option to add him as a
friend on facebook
isn't that doesn't that bother you it
does because i want to say
sorry yeah like and i'm sure and i'm
sure he doesn't even think of me i'm
sure he doesn't even know what the [ __ ]
my name is like i'm sure he's forgotten
all these
all of these things but i'm hanging on
to the fact that like i [ __ ] someone
over so hard
i i don't have like a boy [ __ ] over
story i feel bad about but there is this
one girl for my quaker youth retreats i
did this is like the meanest [ __ ] i've
ever done like
i really felt what i had done to her um
and i'm always looking to find her
because i owe her a pair of shoes all
right so i was in
quaker meeting is like a church that you
but you
there's no past or anything you just sit
in silence and if you feel moved to
speak you stand up so
we're in a silent room sitting on these
benches for like i don't know how long
was an hour
and i'm sitting there and i'm trying to
impress my friend burly this this guy i
was friends with
and i had uh like a thumbtack i used to
just chew on thumbtacks and
was a juvenile i just thought it like
made me like the pin yeah i would just
like i would just play with them i
wanted my tongue pierced so i would just
like [ __ ] around with them
i always was like i don't know it was
just some dumb thing me and my friends
we also had there was a place condom
kingdom on south street in philly and
they had
flavored condoms and we would like bring
them to school like they asked that idea
chew on them and stuff
yeah and then um blow them up for
parties
yeah blow them up for parties those are
the balloons yeah
but so didn't you guys have toys
to put up in you every every happy meal
thing went right up esther's butt i bet
um but i so you never watched
nickelodeon after school or
trl
i was too busy sucking dick to be honest
oh my god
if you ask anybody in high school that
was my reputation just
it went a little bit overboard because i
feel like i really only truly
sucked maximum three penises in high
school but
three people they called her tiny reflex
lady
no gag i'm trying to make a terrible
thing
um but you know three might as well be
90 when you're
oh my god right because that's how they
see it they're like oh
if you've sucked one deck you're a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] yeah and so that's what i
was labeled i was a face
queen i used to well i had a kid that
ice queen that's what they used to call
us face queen chicken head those were
two
that you suck a lot of dick and even
though like it was really only three
yeah but i i there was a kid that i
hooked up with
he came into my school this guy he um
he was cute he was short he was cute but
i was like still so into my first
boyfriend who was like
who was fully dating becky at that point
but so
um this kid came to my school and he
tried to hang out with me and wanted me
to suck his dick and i
just didn't want to hook up i just
wasn't into him i didn't hook up with
him
so then he did tell everyone he went
around i was like this [ __ ] doesn't
suck dick like he like spread the rumor
that i was the opposite
which then got my friend shane's dick
sucked because then i was like i'm just
like one of your dicks
to prove this but anyway that kid that
that spread that rumor
was motorcycle racing when he was 18. he
crashed didn't die stood up triumphantly
after the crash then was hit by a car
and did die
so if you want to spread a rumor about
me go for it you will die young
oh my gosh that is so sad
that he said that about me annie
he would be in prison he okay so he
actually he went to jail before that
because he went and someone told me this
like through the grapevine because i
hadn't i
don't really talk to anyone from my high
school only a couple people but
someone had told me through the
grapevine they're like oh did you know
that drew is in prison
he must not have been 18. he must have
been in his early 20s he was jerusalem
went to prison
because he went to my ex-boyfriend's
house
where he still lived in the basement
with the water bed and shot up
his room and i was like oh my god is he
and then
he was like no brad's fine i was like no
no did he get the water bed and i was
like
i hope he didn't pop the water bed did
he
he didn't what's the point of shooting
up a room
if you're not going to shoot the water
back i know how snake is that scene of
just squirting water
it's a very 80s like very very like
you know miami 80s um um
yeah mafia movies yeah booting up the
[ __ ] water bath yeah that would be a
yeah
by the way on a water bed you have to
deal with like sea sick
everything's like there's so many added
things wait is a water bed still
do people still have i don't think so
that sounds so much fun i remember
we got one for the studio we should you
guys
there was um in the in this one island
that we would frequent in the
philippines called dumaguete there was
this one hotel called the habitat
and if you paid extra money for the best
room in their hotel it was a water bed
and i remember like my dad my mom my
cousins all of us would just like
squish squish on the water better you
roll over someone flies up
we felt so rich we felt that the riches
i ever felt today it was like a
pricey bed you know it was it's probably
the equivalent to having like a
really nice like tempur-pedic now do you
think jeff bezos has a water bed
i bet he does he has like a factory
where they make water beds at least
but so he but he spread a rumor about me
when i lost my virginity he told
everyone that i [ __ ] like a dead fish
and i remember taking like
i was like i mean i was technically i
was swimming on the thing
you [ __ ] like a dead you didn't [ __ ] a
dead fish he said i [ __ ] like a dead
fish i'm like i'm sorry i was
14 losing my virginity on your [ __ ]
water bed swimming
flailing around also there's a guy out
there that will like that one day
okay and but he's already engaged to ask
you
i have necrophilia but i like being a
dead person
it's just that's when she says that her
neck hurts a lot you know i have a
friend who does
um um quite what she calls like quad
play
like quadriplegia play where she
pretends to be
completely like um incapable
of like doing anything for herself so
that's one of the sex things that she
does so she makes her husband
um do sexual things while she's like i
can't move this and then dude
yeah she was like oh i don't have nerves
there can you move to the right
she does it and then she starts to like
drool and so he has like wipe her mouth
but it's quadriplegic play oh my god i
want to do that
for like chores
i'm role-playing that you're the maid
and i'm here sick
that is so intense oh my god i'm like
i'm very lit up by that i feel an
energy because you know you're gonna
have to put less energy in later
[Laughter]
esther i i have a question when you
would drive in 2020 when you drove past
johnny rocket boy's
house did he still live there no it's
his parents house but yeah and what are
their thoughts on it
i don't know his parents i'm sure they
don't like me
well they've built a gated community
around their house
but nobody's ever seen me i've never
seen anyone outside that's kind of the
dream it's
you know what it is i'm gathering
information i'm spying you know what
that
there's a book called the dutch house
there's a book called a dutch house
that's not a dutch oven which
i'm sure you're involved in a lot but
it's basically that it's like brother
sister who had like this really
they couldn't figure out what memories
they really had in that house so they go
back
every year and they park outside that
house and they process their lives
just outside this house because that's
where a lot of heartache and confusion
happened
that's amazing flowers in the attic is
that with flowers in the attic flowers
in the attic was the kids
had to bang each other up in the attic
ew oh my god siblings yeah have you guys
never don't say oh that's her actual
life
it's it's my addict
but yes like i'm revisiting my past i'm
and that's i if i were to connect with
him that's all i want to do is just like
oh let's relive our childhood like we
were children
he's like do you know much therapy i've
gone through to forget you exist [ __ ]
anyways no i have that too where it's
like but mine is a little bit later
i don't i'm not in love with him okay i
just
even though some would say dave looks
like him
i just want to live my
pass over again like every other normal
healthy adult
right don't you guys want that yeah but
that's the thing
i my childhood and my high school years
that is like happiness to me that's
because i think you there was a
question we were talking about like
what's a memory you want to like cement
and relive
yes that's that's it for me like
childhood in high school
once i hit college everything got shady
um that's what i wanted to ask you guys
um so last week you said you were raised
by slugs
right and it really does track and then
i came across this article about
it's called mollusk manipulation where
scientists are able to take snails
and they're able to extract delete or
replace
memories and i wanted to ask you guys
because they're studying it to see if
maybe
one day they can do that with humans
with ptsd anxiety depression or just
really bad like
trauma in the past it's kind of like a
um eternal sunshine for the spotless
mind
um if they're my question to you guys is
if that was one day possible what
what what memories would you permanently
delete
what memories would you reinforce so
it's clear as day
in the forefront of your minds and what
random thing that never really happened
in your real life
would you place in there i have trouble
with these sort of questions because
i do really my entire i've put all my
eggs in the basket of
it's okay these terrible things happened
because they've led me here
and i am really at a place in my life
where i [ __ ]
love my life i'm i totally feel
like in line with who i am and happy
with what i do
and able to kind of um
get through my life happily and and
navigate it but i mean it really was
hard it took a long time to get here
so i'm like i don't know if i would have
ended up here you know because i always
think
here in bobby lee's here in the garage
of a great man and his girlfriend
ish we don't know i would want to
reinforce
my childhood because i feel like like
elementary school
i was so confident and i was just
and like the memories are good and
positive i feel like i would really want
to reinforce that and sometimes do you
ever do this where you like
try to honor your younger self or like
try to revisit who you used to be
like i'll always think like gosh you
know if i feel insecure about this like
let me get in touch with like childhood
esther who is super confident
and like let me honor and respect her by
trying to like be inspired by her
confidence but mine is the opposite
because i'll do
i do like some really [ __ ] cheesy
journaling where i'll write to my inner
child and stuff
but mine is because any sort of like
hiccup or triggering i have as a
grown-up
is like because of something that was
hard when i was little so i have to go
back
and instead of like learning lessons
from this kid i have to tell this kid
that i like got her back you know
and it's weird i'll have like a like my
inner child will write back to me
it's so [ __ ] weird it's like a kid is
writing to me it's very strange
i like that but i have to like go help
her rather than you know like an eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind when yeah
when they're like she's you know they
like want to go back in time to like she
wants to help him when he had his like
most traumatic
experience that was like really sweet no
so i want to ask you guys
nothing nothing you would permanently
delete
like i mean i guess if i deleted my like
crazy
traumatic high school getting like just
one memory it doesn't have to be a whole
period it just has to be
one thing that you can do without maybe
if i hadn't gotten a i got in a car
accident
when i was 12 on my way to to join like
the
the swim team that was going to train me
for the junior olympics so that to me is
like a very
crazy thing because that's when i
started smoking cigarettes and like
[ __ ] being bad i just like leaned out
of the good
so i just that would be a pivotal moment
i don't know where my life would be
though
i don't know if it would lead me here
yeah i'm not afraid of of alternate
um alternate routes i think that's cool
like i'm not like so hung up on the fact
like look i'm so happy where i ended up
i would have been happy it would have
been okay no matter
where it went and what direction it went
with who it went with
yeah and um there are some things that
in my life that i could definitely do
without there's so many
memories that i could just pluck and say
that didn't need to happen for me to be
you know i who i am today will you tell
us what
yeah like for instance like being um
hurt by my by an older family member at
eight years old
i could do that i could do without that
because there was nothing i could have
done at that age
except it it gave me i think that's when
like my panic attacks and sweating
started
i could do without that um so that would
i would permanently delete that yeah i
want to permanently delete my
hyperhidrosis yeah i'd imagine i mean i
it was true it was it i and esther
doesn't have sweaty armpits
so this is which is very dry pitted
goddess
but it was traumatizing because when did
how old were you when your armpit
started sweating
i think second grade yeah mine were
fourth grade i remember and it was like
you i would pit out and everyone made
fun of me it was like a huge source of
embarrassment
and now i'm saying rocking it
yes with botox i had a friend my i met
this
one of my high school friends and she
also had we were doing like this art
program over the summer and she also had
sweaty armpits
yeah so we rode the train in together
and every day we would just
pretend we got in a water fight and just
spray each other down to make it look
like it wasn't just
the third part of that question what
would you add what
random great memory would you just
randomly insert into
your memory bank i would insert like
winning
sports things i would insert like
finishing things and winning things like
getting good grade like things that were
like positive reinforcement because then
i think i would have more follow-through
in my life now because i think i was
kind of like
i never really finished things because i
didn't i didn't have the
wherewithal to know that you have to
wait to get the feeling of reward
yeah i have this thought that i feel
like wouldn't necessarily change the
trajectory of my life i just want a
memory
of me showering a really
grimy and dirty benicio del toro just
one shower just one should we it doesn't
there's no context
from like excess baggage aid era no like
was eating 21 grams yeah yeah it's just
grimy and fat
benicio del toro and i just want that
random memory because that way
i'll never want for anything again i
just
just randomly be like yeah we did that
didn't we i
showered i got to soap down benicio
i saw him on a plane once i walked into
i was
it was the first time i've ever flown uh
first class
and um i walked in and
to my right or to my left was benicio
del toro and everyone like
that was walking in or i guess i wasn't
in first class because i was walking
through first class
so everyone in front of me i would see
them like go like oh my god and they get
all excited because they'd see benicio
del toro and then i'd see them go two
rows up in first class to look to the
right and they'd go like uh
kept walking and so then i get i get to
rose down and it's clay aiken
[Laughter]
and i was like wow the range of fame to
be in my face like people were so
excited and so pissed and
you know i think that was when he was
like coming out against gay marriage or
something he was like
he was gay yeah no but he was doing
something that was like making the gay
community really mad at him oh
he was like republican or i don't know
if he actually was anti-gay or
it was just something where it was
around the time when gay marriage was
starting to actually become legalized
but people were really mad at him at
that point
but it was just so funny i was like to
be right in my [ __ ] face to see
the different sides of i'm starting my
banana breaks
go ahead i'll tell you how close i got
to benicio del toro as i eat no banana
oh you brought me strawberries ah george
strawberry banana break give her a
strawberry on her stomach give her a
little
george that is so nice of you are they
organic
oh my god they are what if you threw
them on the ground
they're from ralph's you just trash them
i'm so excited i was gonna eat my my
gummies but can you stop being excited
it's hard for me to get my food down
when you're happy
i um when one one year bobby and i went
to go um christmas tree shopping
and i don't know why the guy needed to
insert this information
but he was like oh yeah um benicio del
toro just shopped for a christmas tree
yesterday
and i have gone to the same christmas
tree every year
i will not stray from that one you go at
halloween
every day every day thanksgiving to like
the day after christmas
but that's how that's how obsessed i was
with him for a very long time
i feel like i could maybe benefit from
like some happy memories with extended
family
you know like i that was always a really
hard area for me
so just because my dad had me so late in
life
and he always talks about like how there
was so many relatives that would gather
at my the house you know where i grew up
and so that always kind of [ __ ] with me
like thinking about all this
like family that i could have had but
was too late for i always feel like like
i missed out late to the party
never met my grandparents like and
so i feel like i would i have this hole
in me like this deep hole in me
that i would it would probably be good
for me if i didn't have it because it
does [ __ ] with me
yeah and like another thing too i i
can't remember i've
talked about this but like my dad when
his
mom died he was like oh i'm never having
children
so he gave all her stuff away he gave
all her jewelry like all of her
belongings
so that also i'm like oh i like would
love to have like a
necklace of hers or something but that i
will admit has given me
like a less materialistic view of life
because i'm like oh i can still
like love her essence and you know
without having some of her stuff
and also it's so much pressure to have
like heirlooms right when you lose
if you get robbed it's like the it's the
only thing you don't want unreplaceable
things
in your life for me at least i don't i
never want like i'm always like oh
when i get something sentimental i'm
like [ __ ] i i agree the only thing that
i don't own jewelry
that has any real meaning to it um i
don't get it
i try not to attach myself to objects
too much
you guys not today hold on one second
this is exactly how it went down you
guys
[Laughter]
the night drive oh that feels kind of
good
it's cooling imagine it was hot out
there in the philippines but she would
wind it back like she would just be like
so sad feel sad shout out to my mommy i
love her so much
i know i guess yeah if there were more
like memories maybe my dad
because my dad worked a lot my dad and i
bonded when i was 15. he grad
he graduated he retired early and i was
getting my
learner's permit and that's when i
stopped being a juvenile delinquent like
the minute my dad was around
really and i had yeah time i just wanted
i think i just needed adult attention
that wasn't
so bad i needed less adult attention and
more if you know what i mean
um but we yeah we would we would drive
around we would do so much fun stuff my
dad and i and that was when things were
good so i think if i'd had that a little
bit younger that could have helped
because i definitely didn't feel safe as
a kid but i do think that made me like
prepared for the world in a way that i
wouldn't be if i had been
but that's also kind of a sad thing to
say that
bad things have to happen to you for you
to be a wise woman
yeah but i also kind of do like
sometimes i do think like when i think
about all the
lessons that i've learned it's through
like a pain because when i look at my
um teenager now like jules lives with us
she
is so aware she's your niece she's my
niece yeah she's not your daughter
she's esther's jealous she's like if
anyone's your daughter it's me
but she's so aware and so
just she just knows she has had so much
more guidance that i did
and i don't think it needs we don't need
to be pain to learn
right and we just need to be told and
you know i never learned it the way she
learned it
and so she's very she's just switched on
when it comes to
you know what her boundaries are with
like you know with her body and things
like that she just is very
way more switched on than i was there
okay so for that to work though
she needs to have someone in her life
that
has learned those boundaries however
they learn them to teach her like my mom
i i give my mom as much grace as i
possibly can because
i think about she just was didn't have
the life i had so she didn't know when
she was like
sending me off and all these like pretty
much they could have been like suicide
missions
pretty i was like crazy she
just thought that wait you were you were
part of the 911 i mean
that would have had more of a goal and
more thought and planning behind it but
there was always danger but
she didn't she was her mother was very
like overprotective to her my mom lived
a very nice
life where nothing like that happened to
her so a lot of the things that she let
me do
that in retrospect i look back and i go
why the [ __ ] would she let me do is
because it was something that
when she was a kid she wasn't allowed to
do and she was looked at
as like this thing that she missed out
on it's been interesting for me living
with dave because he's so
healthy like he is just i have learned
so much living with him because
he is so it's a healthy person his
childhood his upbringing parents sister
everyone was just
normal like i know we think that that's
not a thing but
i see it in him and it it's pretty
crazy and it's wonderful because it's
like
that's how that's how we describe george
like we couldn't be
we couldn't have more starkly different
upbringings
but the reason that i have so much trust
in him
is because he has tools that i don't
have yeah like i may
he just has these his bandwidth is
endless
and i it like amazes me how much he can
do in one day without feeling stressed
out how he can
take handle like really high pressure
situations and just be really chill
and cool about it and i don't have those
tools like him like my bandwidth
is this small when you see someone
managing their emotions in front of you
you're like what the
this is amazing yeah but i feel that way
about todd too he's so
um he's so securely attached like he's
just so willing to he lets things like
roll off of him like nothing sticks on
him
i have anxious attachment yeah i'm like
where are you going
he's like i'm just going to bathroom
stop asking me what are you doing you
know what i do every night i'm on my
computer
like i have to know everything i i
requested to have the bathroom door
taken off the other day
i don't like when you're in there taking
a shirt
bobby is like a cat sometimes he just
disappears and when he wants affection
he has to
come and tell you he wants it you can't
just give it to him because he'll be
like yeah i don't want it
not now but he has that same weird he
doesn't want to admit to it but that
same anxious attachment yeah
anywhere i go if i drive off somewhere
to just live my life
where are you when are you coming back
mama
all the time all day long and then when
i come back home i swear it's like
i think this is as close as par this is
probably i imagine this is what parents
feel when they come home
okay i have um i have a really bad hand
experience and but i want to start off
with annie
um getting um hannah on her dick and how
long she thinks it's gonna stay there
i yeah i know i have her i have always
had this this dream you know when
someone falls asleep first apart i know
you've never partied you just
never eat you fall asleep have you ever
been um drawn on well
because everyone knows if you do that to
esther what happens esther
tell us what the what the repercussions
are a lot of trouble
what kind of tattling legal
issues litigation we should tell your
ex-boyfriend to just draw on your face
when you fall asleep so you leave him
alone forever
i can finally get rid of you i mean my
friend john and i didn't talk for six
months because he gave me a wet willie
that was like i cannot i still can't
believe he did it like i just can't
believe he did that
what what was that apology like did he
have to say i'm sorry i gave you a
willy like begrudgingly apologize no it
was six months of not speaking
and then it was like okay i guess like
we miss each other
what is this henna tattoo i just have
always thought okay so when you fall
asleep early at a party and you haven't
emotionally held everyone captive enough
that that they feel free to [ __ ] with
you a little bit
um they draw dicks on your face so i
always thought it'd be funny to get to
draw like a henna tattoo on someone's
face
of a dick because they last like two
weeks two weeks
so i was asking my eyebrow woman who
does we have the same eyebrow lady aruna
aruna
uh threading she's incredible i love her
she
i asked her i was like how and she was
like there's ways you might be able to
get it off but she i think she is
possibly down
to some pain whoever loses the next
challenge gets a henna dick on them
i mean esther's none let's be real it's
either i we just have to find something
i lose because i'm the only one that's
willing to do that no i'm willing okay
but let me tell you i'll be the judge
how about that
you guys have to completely never be the
you're never the judge i've already
i've already been punished we'll never
give you your dream job the judge
you're a simon cowell i am i think
you're a simon cowell
i'm a randy i'm a [ __ ] randy you're a
paula
i'm paula all [ __ ] up on drugs i will
what if we all commit to getting a henna
on our face
okay i'm not getting a penis but i'll
get
well let me tell you what do you think
this is re this is um
if you get a labia on your cheek i'll be
so happy
but it's just a tiny little rosebud
maybe no maybe i'll get like a little
star
or something like right under your eye
like a [ __ ] little yellow star of
david why do you get numbers
i can't believe you said that i'm
stumped
i'm [ __ ] stopped wait
i've already been punished um i've
already gone through trial by henna
before
because i went to a bollywood wedding so
this is what
we were told all the girls in the bridal
party were like we're all getting hannah
and i was looking at all of their
their pictures and they're like oh it's
amazing and so i went to this lady in
the corner
they had three ladies out and this is
the only lady with no one
getting no one was going up to her so i
was like oh there's
there's an empty stall there i'm gonna
get it done by that lady so i pulled up
this picture i was like this is exactly
what
i want this is right before the wet
wedding i'm i'm going to be in my
full you know garb and look amazing the
next day
and i flew all the way to new york with
this amazing [ __ ] bollywood wedding
i said give me that and george show them
what she gave me
oh they they're jumping into a corpse
keep going george show the finger one
what is that that's really scary
oh my god there's no way that's what
they did to you
that's the only last two [ __ ] weeks i
had to have [ __ ]
my i just looked like we got to fly that
one out i looked dead you looked dead it
looked like i had just
like just did this to just a pile of
[ __ ] i would take that hand over
esther's current hands you mean a hand
model hand
okay she's really let herself go those
hands look like what i should look like
when people are having sex with me
so we're going to do that then that's
the deal with shake on it okay
henna tattoo on the face and he has to
get a large penis
okay how about this yesterday would you
settle for just a really large
mole no
yeah can we get um hair coming out of
the mall
anadon i'll try to think of something
somewhat embarrassing
all right well thanks for watching
bloodbath guys i have a clothing line
sleepoverbyester.com it might be out by
the time this episode comes out
if people want to look at it can you be
a little more excited about your own
product i mean this is
like a sleep but it's just like don't
she's like don't sleep on sleep over by
us
emphasis on the sleep go out and get
yours soon
sleepoverbyester.com welcome to
sleepover by astronaut handmade luxury
loungewear you may have seen it um on
esther's body non-stop for the past six
months
but this is a surprising new one they're
gonna be so good i have tried them on
they're very comfortable
you guys are gonna [ __ ] love them
thank you sweet annie you guys thank you
for listening to this show
look is it traumatizing yeah are we
[ __ ] up yes are they more [ __ ] up
than me
yeah um but please like this
video subscribe comment definitely make
sure you subscribe because i know some
of you haven't subscribed yet and we
need you too and we need you to go over
to itunes and leave us
some reviews and some stars and we need
to hear from you
if you want us to keep doing this show
that's a threat
it's a threat from a little handed girl
she's going to come at you with her
little hands
we love you guys you guys thank you so
much we'll see you next week thank you
follow us
on instagram
[Music]
you